welcome the founder of the honest
company
jessica alba
hi hey are you they're not alone
i know i love you so much i'm so
i'm so happy for you thank you
my friend this extraordinary woman who
changed the world
you ipo'd for honest company yesterday
i saw you ringing the bell with your
beautiful child in your arms your
company
is going to be estimated at about
1.4 billion
dollars
when you were little did you ever see
this happening
no i mean this is like i i had this idea
to create this company because
it just made sense that people shouldn't
have to choose between
what what works and what's good for them
and putting people's health
and wellness and thinking about the
planet and sustainability
and then also like diversity and
inclusion and
representation and all of those values
to me is is really i think
why we've been able to to take the
business to this point
and um and also the connection with
charity and baby to baby and giving back
which you're also part of
so you know i just i feel like this is
the beginning
of our next chapter and i'm just i i
with my kids and my husband it's like
it's been such a journey
getting to this point and and i'm just
thrilled and i hope that you know
when our kids when our girls are are
grown that
there's a lot more of people that look
like us that are in this position
because
we're still you know so uh
in in all of business in government and
all these in all these different ways so
i hope that you know by me being here
it's like a little tiny step forward we
can chip away
by you being here chip away right and
and so let's do our part in just making
sure i think
uh and just making it easier for
everyone to be represented
in every sector you know i'm really
excited that that we got to this point
i just can't believe i'm so happy and by
the way
i am just remember never been killed
wait no okay wait look i pulled up some
pictures for us
there we go i mean that was us back in
the day
i'm just saying i mean
it's wild it's so wild and you believed
in me when i was just a
scrappy little nugget just trying to
like get a job
i have another picture pulled up where
i'm you know with you at a baby to baby
event i'm
pregnant with my second daughter frankie
in that
and i have looked to you
as an example honestly as
a mom and a friend you know
what you guys do with baby to baby and
i'm just so passionate about
what you do you're you give back so much
you
you set the tone for how we're supposed
to be
now all of my cleaning products you know
are in your sustainable bottles
and actually a lot of my sustainability
uh or the values around sustainability
come from my grandma just to bring it
back around to why we're here today and
and you know playing homage to
you know our our family and our family
members but my
grandma she would reuse and recycle
everything every like margarine tub
that was our tupperware we didn't go and
buy extra stuff
she would you know macgyver everything
everything had
five different uses and so i take that
sensibility when i was
building um honest you know you you pull
a lot from your own life experience and
and then
you know upcycling recycling reusing
um that's just embedded in who i am as a
person i hate wasting things you know
that's exactly why you went on that path
and i went on the path of my mother set
as an example which was studio 54 in
hollywood
so now i'm awake uh in this new arena
and i love our lives i wouldn't trade
him for a thing
reading this book i was like i want to
quit my job and this is the best
book i've ever read in the cookbook
world because it is a lifestyle it is
a philosophy and a mentality and we're
going to meet the authors
of grand dishes please welcome iska
lupton
and anastasia miyarahi
hi drew hi anna
we're good we're good yeah yeah i just
got very excited because she saw you
holding her book in your hands
i mean that is your yaya and she's
right here on the cover anastasia
how did the idea of this book come about
because
it it's so different than other
cookbooks to me
because it's beautiful recipes but you
transport us around the world and you
give us wisdom
beyond even the dishes yeah so it
started because i was living in the uk
at the time and i really just wanted a
cookbook of my own
yaya's recipes because she cooks
amazingly well
and then um i guess we did a shoot with
yaya
and iska and our best friend ella and
the photographs came back amazing so we
put them on our instagram account
and then people started contacting us
about their own grandmothers
so we decided to sort of go ahead and
make it a global thing and cook with
grannies from all over the world
anastasia
do you have the same name as your yaya
yes i do
so in greece the grandchildren
always get the grandparents name so it's
almost you're always an ode to your own
grandparents so
anastasia we both have the same name
in latino culture a lot of
mothers and daughters have the same name
really mm-hmm i love it yeah
and then there are certain cultures that
you know men and their
sons have the same name which is more
common
yes exactly i love my grandmother's name
it's dolores
i thought about it i voted for it for my
daughter frankie because i was like in
short it's
dolly it's so cute but she was a frankie
um
but i i love the meaning behind this
book and we're gonna take a quick
commercial break
and then we're going to come back and
it's go what are we going to cook after
the break
we are making yaya's roasted vegetables
which are actually on the cover of the
book
and then satsiki to go with it which is
a kind of garlicky
yogurt i love tzatziki